hey everyone is fair thread sterner
sorry and.com and in this video I want
to show you how to check for cost over
to Beryl tenderness also known as CVA
tenderness this is found in patients who
may have a kidney infection because what
has happened is that the kidney becomes
inflamed from the infection and then
when you take your hand put on the bat
and thump or percuss it will cause the
patient tenderness so let me show you
how to do that okay so what you want to
do is you want to find the last rib
posts király and that is the 12th rib so
if you fill in between the ribs be about
right here and then you're going to find
the spine and underneath the 12th rib
and between the spine is that cost over
to Beryl angle and about right here is
where your left kidney is located and
over here is where your right kidney is
located so what we're going to do is
we're going to take our hand and we're
just going to put it over here we're
going to make a fist and we're going to
thump our hand and we're going to ask
the patient if those have any pain okay
do you have any pain with that okay and
then we're going to do it to the other
side you have any pain okay and if they
had pain that would indicate a possible
kidney infection thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos